I have need of a man with your  qualifications I'm not for sale  I'm a duly sworn Warrant Officer we need  your help we're decent people being  driven from our homes slaughtered in  cold blood so you seek revenge  I seek righteousness but I'll take  revenge we looking with some men through  a job difficult impossible I need more  than a few  they help us fight how many you got so  far  and allow me to show you something  I believe that bears wearing people's  clothes since we're bonding  quite a batch of strays you tell your  boss if he wants in town come see me  are you here fighting someone else's  bike  these people deserve their lives back  take the damn shot  suppose that Undertaker's gonna get some  business out of this deal  this is not going to end we'll how many  men you say  people being driven from our homes  slaughtered in cold blood